then I had this whole other subsex I
don't even know if you know about this
of sex workers and escorts pissed at me
for ruining business really yeah for you
know it's like a doctor lawyer like
client privilege thing and I was like if
that had been the case I wouldn't have
said anything and if I was just trying
to get attention
I've had sex with some way hotter people
that are famous I would have told one of
those stories you know what I mean like
it wasn't a kiss and tell as a matter of
fact I took the money because I didn't
want anybody to know
um but there is that thing like if if
there was a transaction there was a rage
and that's what I went there for then
why was I paid over a decade later and
there's a couple things that as I've
been mulling this over
um
pretty obsessively in the last two weeks
like because it doesn't matter how many
times you put a fact out and you try to
tell people that they just
you know what I mean